heading out into the mediterranean sea
from the tunisian port city of gabis the
dive team's part of efforts to prevent
what activists warn could be an
environmental catastrophe
they were sent to inspect the hull of
the sunken tanker the zelo it went down
on saturday along with 750 tonnes of
diesel
the vessel flying the flag of equatorial
guinea was sailing from egypt to malta
its seven-man crew issued a distress
call on friday evening and sought
shelter from bad weather but the vessel
began taking on water the crew were
later safely brought to shore
tunisia's environment minister is
helping oversee the response she says
the situations under control
this is cargo of fuel oil or diesel it's
very different from oil in that fuel oil
is much less dangerous and tends to
evaporate fairly quickly we think the
hull is still watertight and there's no
leakage at the moment
authorities say barriers are being set
up to limit the spread of fuel and any
spillage would be mopped up
but local fishermen are angry their
livelihood relies on the waters where
the tanker is lying
the world wildlife fund says the area is
a fishing ground for 600 sailors with
the wider gulf providing jobs for around
34 000 others
we demand that specialists go down into
the sea and unload all the materials
inside if a leakage occurs we will not
have anything as we already only have a
little part of the sea left to live on
tunisia says several countries have
offered to help out to prevent any
pollution alexia o'brien al jazeera